elimination reactions are reactions that
form alkenes these elimination reactions
occur with the same substrates that
undergo sn1 and sn2 so we'll need to be
able to recognize the conditions that
favor substitution and elimination let's
begin by briefly reviewing an sn1
reaction this tertiary alcohol can be
treated with HCl this will result and
the protonation of the alcohol to make
it a good leaving group an intermediate
carbo cation will form and then the CL
minus will come back and attack
producing this product this reaction
competes with an elimination reaction
called t1 let's take our same alcohol
but instead of treating it with an acid
that contains a good nucleophile CL
minus is a good nucleophile let's treat
it with an acid that has a conjugate
base that's not very nucleophilic
sulfuric acid will do again we get
protonation of the alcohol it leaves on
its own and we form this intermediate
carbo cation hso4 minus is very
resonance stabilized it's not going to
want to attack this carbo cation instead
something in the solution is going to
deprotonate one of the hydrogen atoms
adjacent to the carbo cation so here's
one of these hydrogen atoms drawn out
sulfuric acid
even when concentrated contains a bit of
water so I'm gonna draw that out water
is more basic than the conjugate base of
sulfuric acid and so we'll show this
doing a deprotonation to form an alkene
and the product we'll get looks like
this now let's review sn2 reactions for
our example we'll start with 2-chloro
butane treat it with sodium cyanide and
in a single step we'll get replacement
of chlorine with our nucleophile CN
minus giving a product with inversion of
stereochemistry you may have guessed it
based on sn1 and e1 the reaction that
competes with sn2 is called e 2 for this
example let's use 2-bromobutane
we'll treat this with sodium methoxide
and for good measure will heat it
elimination reactions are favored at
higher temperatures
so elimination reactions will typically
be carried out at room temp or above
under these strong base conditions
instead of substituting the bromine with
the ome the ome is instead going to
attack a proton on the carbon next door
just like the sn2 mechanism e two takes
place in one step the methoxide attacks
the proton these electrons push in to
form our alkene and bromine is
eliminated from this reaction we'll get
a mixture of alkenes resulting from the
arrow pushing i've shown here with the
less crowded alkene being the major
product the reaction gives 81% of this
mixture now we're also going to get 19%
of another product now this product is
formed from elimination on this carbon
giving a less substituted alkene what I
mean by less substituted is you see on
the alkene we have two hydrogen's on
this side and on this side we have one
hydrogen and one alkyl group whereas in
these alkenes we have one alkyl group
sticking off of each side and then one
hydrogen so these have two substituents
coming off of the alkene whereas this
just has the one the propensity to form
the more substituted alkenes as the
major product is referred to as
zaitsev's rule you may see this spelled
a few different ways maybe with an S
here that is because the name is
originally Russian so this is our
attempt to translate it into Latin
characters this less substituted product
is sometimes referred to as the Hofmann
product under specific reaction
conditions with specific leaving groups
we can favor the Hofmann product in
these reactions we won't have time to go
over that in this video but you can look
that up if you need to know it okay I
want to introduce one more related
elimination mechanism this is called II
1 C B let's show an example
when we treat this compound with sodium
hydroxide and maybe warm it up a little
bit we get this product of elimination
now this might seem a little confusing
in the previous videos we talked about
hydroxide being a poor leaving group and
it still is but this mechanism is a
little bit different and it allows
hydroxide to leave let's look at why
first we'll draw out the proton that we
want to deprotonate NaOH comes in and
removes that proton and when we remove
this instead of just pushing the
electrons up onto carbon we'll be able
to take these electrons and push them
through the conjugated system so we
remove our proton form a double bond
here and push electrons up on to oxygen
now this deprotonation is our slow rate
determining step with the assistance of
this pushing the electrons back down and
pushing this double bond over now
hydroxide can leave and produce this
product called an N own I think e 1c B
is pretty easy to recognize because what
you'll have is a leaving group even a
poor leaving group two carbons away
usually from a carbonyl or some anion
stabilising group but this is the really
typical example that you'll probably
need to know for undergraduate ochem in
both II 1 and E 2 reactions the e alkene
is favored so with these groups on the
opposite sides not this z product with
the groups on the same side we'll need
to look at the transition states for
these reactions to see why that is so
now in this particular a one example we
had this symmetrically substituted carbo
cation it eliminated and doesn't really
give an e or z alkene since we don't
have substituents on this side let's
look at an example where we get the e
alkene and we have a choice between e
and z if we treat this with h2 so4 will
produce a carbo cation now a base is
going to come in and deprotonate here
this group could be in this orientation
and the transition state might look like
this
our bass is coming in forming a partial
bond with this hydrogen we have a
partial double bond forming here and
Delta positive character where the carbo
cation is we can also envision another
conformation where this ch3 is flipped
down and the bass is coming in from the
top we have the bass coming in and
starting to form a bond with the
hydrogen the hydrogen is breaking a
double bond is forming and we still have
a little bit of partial positive
character at that carbon atom well in
this transition state it's more crowded
this phenyl and ch3 are on the same side
they're kind of bumping into each other
we have this steric interaction and
because of the steric hindrance this
transition state is going to be favored
with the groups on opposite sides
leading to the formation of the e alkene
preferentially now in the simple example
of the e2 reaction that we outlined
above we get the zaitsev's products with
formation of the e alkene as major this
is because in that example there are
actually two alpha protons that we can
deprotonate however as we'll see near
the end of the video there are important
exceptions to zaitsev's rule with e2
eliminations in order to identify these
we have to be able to look at the
transition state carefully so let's get
into that now in order to do this
elimination all in one step the molecule
needs to adopt one of two confirmations
this conformation is called
anti-periplanar the way this is drawn
this hydrogen this carbon-carbon bond
and the leaving group are all in the
same plane they're drawn in the plane of
the paper whereas these groups on the
tetrahedral carbon are pointing forward
and back and forward and back the groups
can also be syn Perry planar and so here
the hydrogen and the leaving group are
again in the same plane up here but
they're on the same side of the molecule
the reason that Perry planar geometry is
so important real
rates to molecular orbital's I'm gonna
draw these two look like P orbitals
there SP hybrid orbitals at this point
that are turning into P orbitals but the
p orbital is just a little easier to
draw so I'm going to do that right now
so this hydrogen atom is in its orbital
and this leaving group is in an orbital
facing the same direction as we're
deprotonating here we're starting to
form a new PI bond so these orbitals
need to be lined up in the same
direction so that we can have good
orbital overlap in the transition state
with the anti-periplanar geometry same
story let's draw an orbital for our
hydrogen atom and one for our leaving
group and as this pi bond is forming
these will line up the transition states
will look like this for the
anti-periplanar transition state the
bases forming a partial bond to hydrogen
that bond is breaking to carbon we have
the double bond partially forming and a
breaking bond to our leaving group in
the CIN parry planar transition state we
have the base coming in all of these
partial bonds and the X group is
breaking leaving from the top that
allows for our good orbital overlap but
one thing that we need to notice about
the synperiplanar transition state is
that we have eclipsing interactions in
order for the hydrogen and the leaving
group to get into plane these groups are
eclipsed with each other so although e
two eliminations can proceed by the
synperiplanar elimination transition
state the anti-periplanar is much more
favored since these groups are actually
staggered in the Newman projection
because this anti parry planar geometry
is so important that need two reactions
being able to see this is important for
predicting the products you'll get from
reactions let's look at two examples
we'll apply a Newman projection and a
chair to make sure that you can deal
with these types of problems when you
see them here's our first problem this
chloride when treated with NaOH is going
to predominantly give one single product
predict that product
okay to approach this we need to draw a
Newman projection and I find it easy to
add all my groups in we have some
implied hydrogen atoms here and here and
I want to account for those in my Newman
so I'm just going to draw them with
their appropriate stereochemistry now so
here we have a hydrogen coming out at us
and this one is going into the page now
for our Newman projection we need to
imagine we're looking down the
carbon-carbon bond where the alkyne is
going to form to do that we need to look
down this carbon-carbon bond so let's
draw the front of our Newman projection
so here's my front carbon and I'm gonna
keep my phenyl ring pointing downward
what I'm thinking of doing is lifting
this up and turning it so I can look
down this bond and now this ch3 is
pointing backward into the piece of
paper so when I turn this up it's going
to be on the left side now let me draw
the lines for the substituents on the
back carbon this phenyl ring was in
plane with this phenyl ring and so these
should be lined up the phenyl is going
to go across from this phenyl and now
we're still turning the molecule this
way and so this hydrogen was pointing
back it's going to come around like this
and end up over here on my Newman
projection and the CL that was forward
is going to be on the same side as the H
so I'm gonna put that right here if it
was hard for you to see how I drew in
the groups on this Newman you might want
to use your model kit at first build the
molecule you're looking at turn it in
space you can physically turn your model
and then you can look down that carbon
atom for real and draw out your Newman
projection now if we had a choice of two
hydrogen atoms to deprotonate here we'd
put them both in an anti-periplanar
conformation with the leaving group and
see which newman was the lowest energy
that would be the one with least steric
interactions and that's why we often get
the e alkene however here we only have
one choice of hydrogen atom to
deprotonate so this hydrogen here and
this chlorine need to become
anti-periplanar if I envision moving my
back carbon to do that
the chlorine will have to move here turn
here the hydrogen will turn up the
phenyl ring will come where the chlorine
was so I've just drawn some arrows to
show that rotation and then let's draw
what we get we kept our front carbon
atom oriented the same way so let's just
redraw these groups in the same spot and
now we'll draw our back carbon with
everything rotated 120 degrees I've
circled these in red they're the groups
that are going to be eliminated and now
it gets pretty easy for me to see the
product from this particular structure
these groups are going to be on the same
side of the alkene on different carbon
atoms and these groups are going to be
on the same side of the alkene now if
that's not super easy for you to see I
would redraw this with the hydrogen and
chlorine eliminated and then stretch out
these groups so that there are a hundred
and eighty degrees from each other the
way were we're looking at them so on our
front carbon our phenyl is down the
hydrogen is gone and then our ch3 group
is going to adjust upward on the back
carbon atom we're losing chlorine so
we'll need to position our phenyl and
our hydrogen okay so now in this
projection we're looking down a double
bond so let's straighten that out and
draw our product up here so here's our
alkene if we're turning this this way
the ch3 group will be pointing up over
here and the phenyl will be pointing
down and now our hydrogen atom is on the
same side as the ch3 and the phenols are
both on the same side so this example
actually produces a z alkene because of
the stereochemistry at these carbon
atoms another case where the
anti-periplanar geometry becomes very
important is chair cyclohexane for this
problem we're treating this cyclohexane
with a tosylate leaving group with
strong base nao ET now in these a cyclic
examples we form the more substituted
alkene as the major product but in this
case we need to make sure by drawing a
chair that hydrogen atoms are actually
anti-periplanar to our leaving group
there's a hydrogen
here that can eliminate to form the more
substituted alkene and there's two
hydrogen atoms here that are also
potentially able to eliminate so let's
draw our chair begin with your two
parallel lines draw two more parallel
lines and finally connect everything now
in order to adopt the anti-periplanar
geometry on the chair we actually need
our groups to be axial so we'll have an
axial hydrogen atom and an axial leaving
group will allow for the anti Perry
planar geometry this o tousle group is
above the ring
that's our leaving group and so I
already know that I need to get these
substituents axial for anti-periplanar
geometry in the elimination and so what
I'm going to do is choose a position to
start out for the tousle group where
this can be axial up
well this point right here has an axial
up position and then the equatorial
position sticking out so I'll place my o
tousle group here okay coming
counterclockwise we have this ch3 group
pointing down well here counterclockwise
this is our position that we're
traveling in and the group needs to be
down on this carbon we have an
equatorial position that's pointing up
and an axial position pointing down so
right here is where our methyl group is
going to go and this light blue line is
where our hydrogen atom is well that
hydrogen atom
that could form the more substituted
alkene by elimination is actually not
anti-periplanar to our tousle group
instead we're going to have to use one
of the hydrogen atoms that's on this
carbon to do our elimination because one
of those is going to be anti-periplanar
so now the sodium ethoxide can come in
it'll deprotonate this anti-periplanar
hydrogen atom the electrons can push in
eliminating our tousle group with good
orbital overlap so we were able to use
this chair to see that it's one of these
hydrogen atoms that needs to eliminate
and that this one is not in the correct
geometry to do so in the next video in
this series I'm going to summarize what
we know about substitute
and elimination reactions for each of
the substrates that were familiar with
but I want to leave you with just one
thought here and that's that strong base
really promotes e to eliminations and so
it's good to leave off with some
examples of these strong bases so before
we quit let's make a little list of
these we have hydroxide this could be in
the form of NaOH or Koh we have the
ethoxide
om e - o et - I'll just put o R here
usually these have a sodium counter ion
so you might see na ome or na o et a
common very hindered base that is used
often in eliminations is a form of this
but it's sodium tert-butoxide this
tert-butyl group is very large so this
base is good at promoting elimination
even on primary halides some nitrogen
centered bases that you might see in
these reactions are na NH 2 so we can
write this as NH 2 - and another
compound that is sometimes seen is
lithium diisopropyl amador Lda this is
another nitrogen centred base that looks
like this it has a lithium counter ion
the trend you should be noticing here is
the negative charge on either oxygen or
nitrogen that makes quite strong bases
and strong bases and heat will favor e 2
eliminations